hello freak [ __ ] people really enjoy
you when they're the only ones to know
about you and then as you started
getting bigger and bigger to start
looking for holes yeah we blew that up
early though yeah we blew that we blew
it up really early we made a lot of
enemies really early which is crazy
because I mean the enemies I made in the
early 90s I mean I still have them and
they're still sort of lurking out there
in various holes it's weird it's like
those those those you know inner scene
rivalries never end you know between
bands or it's like I've had weird
experiences with like people not with
nirvana people but like people who were
in the Nirvana world they're still like
this weird like because I'm from pumpkin
world right like P times I'll have weird
stuff happen and I'll dig down and find
out it was like somebody who used to
work in nirvana world trying to cut my
ankles 27 years late like so weird like
so parochial the whole Nirvana scene is
a very strange scene you know whenever
the the main guy commits suicide in this
oddly conspiratorial way would you watch
that [ __ ] up movie that's no because I
see a lot of people don't know I was
like sort of around for a lot of that
stuff so I know a lot of stuff that I've
never sort of talked about so for me
watching that stuff is like it's a it's
replaying something I don't want to
replay and be I know a lot of the stuff
is not based on fact because I was
around for a lot of it right and no
one's ever talked to me about it so
people tried to pimp me out like in a
Q&A with fans and ask me questions like
I'm certainly gonna to talk about it you
know what I mean yeah that that
documentary was so strange it's like how
does someone get away with that like the
recreations like if you weren't there
you don't know what the [ __ ] they said
so if you don't know what the [ __ ] they
said and you're putting words these
actors mouths you haven't them play it
out like wouldn't you just this should
be illegal because you're gonna make it
so you're creating especially when
you're talking about a murder mystery
yeah you're you're saying that it wasn't
a suicide you're you're at least putting
out the idea that it might be a murder
the way you're doing it is by
manufacturing words that you have no
idea if they were
this is complete fiction yeah so like
that's why I was around for the before
sort of during and and certainly a lot
after and I know a lot of stuff that
again I know is not in the public domain
and so I I go with what I know right you
know I mean yeah but it said that whole
Nirvana thing was I mean I remember the
first time I heard Nirvana I was a kid
in Boston and this buddy of mine played
it for us and we were we had never heard
anything like that we were like whoa
yeah this is it this great thing just
fantastic a new thing right new there's
a crazy little Boston statistic for you
we once played it was Nirvana pumpkins
and bullet la Volta we played at that
little Club it was like an alt Club
across from Fenway I can't read what
it's called
axis or right right yeah but you know we
played there like I don't know 92
it wasn't even sold out oh wow it's like
some a 700 people kind of thing that's
700 people with an awesome story yeah
right Wow
[Applause]
[Music]